I'm entering this log for the record
this is mark Watney and I'm still alive
obviously the scientific accuracy of the
film I think is remarkable
a lot of the typography what they show
in the Martian we could find places on
Mars that look that way and in
particular when they did things like
show overhead views and at Mars
it was the overhead views of Mars that
you would expect to see mom won't he's
still alive the astronaut uses the
lander as a way to communicate back with
earth well to do that he had to plug in
a computer that he had on this vehicle
to our lander well it turns out our
lander had a port that you could plug in
that allowed him to do those exact
things so an astronaut really could have
done that and reprogrammed this vehicle
I gotta figure out how to grow four
years worth of food here on a planet
where nothing grows the fact that he
used potatoes that was one of the crops
that was selected as the best that you
could do in terms of generating calories
I am the greatest botanist on this
planet for oxygen production though it
actually turns out that wheat would be
something better than potatoes but if
you were just looking for calories
potatoes were the right thing to use
1,200 kilometers in diameter bearing 24
point 41 degrees that's tracking right
towards us
the windstorm event my team thought I
was dead the problem is on Mars there's
only 1% of the atmosphere that we have
here on earth so even if you have 100
mile-an-hour winds that has the same
force as a 1 mile an hour wind here on
earth having things blowing around and
people blown across the landscape this
isn't going to happen after that
everything was really really accurate
the first person to touch the surface of
Mars I think is going to be in my
lifetime I think we can easily do it in
20 years if we want to we could do it
less for us the next step is to go to
Mars and bring back samples we're going
to do that next with a mission called
Mars 2020 and that mission is going to
drill into rock and collect core samples
the first time that we study these close
up might very well be with humans that
will go to Mars in the coming decades
I'm pretty sure it's going to be the
most exciting human adventure of all
time